salut c'est Kit Harington pour brute
[Music]
[Applaudissements]
quelle belle chose que tu veux faire
j'ai adoré ça j'adore le faire ça
ne va probablement pas t'apporter de
travail malheureusement mais si c'est ce que tu
aimes faire tu devrais le faire  faites-le et faites-le
aussi longtemps que vous sentez que ce n'est
pas méchant pour vous regardez les écoles de théâtre
regardez aller regardez aller à l'
école de théâtre de type Conservatoire au Royaume-
Uni ou en France ou où que vous
soyez et faites-le faire  ce
serait de cette façon tout d'abord mon conseil, je pense
que c'est la meilleure façon d'entrer dans l'
industrie la qualité principale d'un acteur
probablement un bon ego de taille saine étant
vraiment vraiment vraiment obligé que les
gens vous regardent